[Music]
hey baby we going to be here all day we
going to be here all day baby I like
this kind of
party welcome to the first episode of
the way back I'm Ryan sichler ryan.com
Ryan sichler on all your social media uh
I'm here with my guest on the first
episode ladies and gentlemen Tom sagoro
welcome to the way back tomor way way
back man Way Way Back than for me this
is the back seat in the station wagon
facing out the back no seat belts Dash
on the front cigar smoke probably in the
air no seat belts at all you just see
the grill of a car just come up to here
and you're like you wa did you ever sit
in that seat did you were you old enough
to have that yeah did you ever give the
shoot the finger real quick try to the
what are you kids doing back there
that's St yeah pulling away do it right
now as we pull away buses school other
school they would flick you off if they
saw kids they be like [__] you I want to
talk to you about just like this is all
about Nostalgia growing up and stuff and
your boys who I've hung out with and my
daughter did too we went fishing
together my daughter caught her first
fish with your kids we caught 18 fish in
a turtle yeah out there using hot dog
which I had never fished with in my life
son I took hot dog up here to Kenneth
hon you know what we caught what two
turtles two turtles turtles must love
hot dogs bro I was all fired up like I
got I got a good one I real a turtle but
your kids are wild I've seen stuff on
your guys social media of like keys in
the toilet uh crayon all over the wall
like I have a daughter I remember even
before kids I would sit in a restaurant
and be like look at these [__] boys
are climbing over the [__] and girls are
just sitting there coloring and they're
just you know genetically better than we
are monkeys completely monkeys what's
the wildest stuff you guys used to do
growing up what did you used to do I
mean I think you know we used to take we
used to every thing was riding bikes you
know so like as soon as like you got
home ride bikes we lived in this
neighborhood in the suburbs of
Cincinnati and we would just ride our
bikes and the craziest thing that I
remember doing at that age I'm talking
like seven 8 n was when I lived there
you know I lived there from I was born
and I left when I was nine but in that
age range one time I went to these you
know there was always like a field
always like back through some woods and
one of the kids had an M80 and uh he
just was like oh this is supposed to be
like pretty big firework I didn't really
have a concept of what it was what a
quarter stick of dynamite yeah and when
that that thing blew off I just just
from the impact I already I was like oh
we're in trouble like I I couldn't
believe that we didn't get in trouble I
mean it left the [__] crater you know
we used to put those people's mailboxes
and blow them apart oh yeah it would
blow the sides open and the back off of
it and stuff one time I got a fire going
uh on this like on this stretch of Lake
Michigan when we were in Wisconsin and I
just got cans of spray paint and threw
them them into the fire just as like a
are you serious it was like bombs going
off Mists go flying different colors and
yeah dude but that's just like you don't
think no we used to do Roman Candle
fights shoot them at each other we used
to do we used to take GI Joe's or Star
Wars figures and we would like um tape
like 12 bottle rockets to them and then
light them off and see how see how far
up it could go and then once it blew up
the pieces would all come down we would
shoot fireworks off in the house like we
terrible kids now my kids also like they
when they when I found Ellis painting
the walls with his hands I [__] lost
my mind did you ever do anything like I
didn't do anything like that as I one
time put I thought I was helping I put
water in my dad's lawn mower where you
put all the gas oh [__] it all up and
he was he was real nice about it he was
like did you put something in here I was
like mm he was like if I promise you're
not in trouble will you tell me and I go
I put water in there for
for you for you filled it
up he was like okay uh but I was like
flipping out at Ellis the [__] paint
all over the what are you doing just
going crazy he was like what do they do
he goes I don't like when you yell at me
when you raise your voice I'm just a kid
he says that yeah he goes if you just
talk to me in a normal voice I'm like
dude and I just start laughing because
he's being like he's right and he's
being like rational I'm like why are you
painting the walls he goes sometimes my
brain man my brain
man tells me to do stuff I was
like okay I love it dude yeah yeah I
love your kids I hung out with both of
them they were beating the [__] out of
me fresh out of spinal surgery I was
like okay okay and
like Brian came you know he's two girls
he has two little girls and you could
tell he's like so gentle he's so gentle
with them and the way he speaks and like
hey guys and he's like he's with these
two sweet girls all the time and like he
crawls into the trampoline thing and as
he's on all because you have to crawl in
as he's on all fours Ellis grabs him by
the neck and and Julian just starts
kicking him like he just starts to he's
like guys hey guys guys and I was like
this is what it is dude he's like guys
you just see him start to panic panic
he's panicking and and looked at me too
like she got it so they called a dish
and then the boys wanted to put it we on
the trampoline and I was like go ahead
put it on the trampoline so they put it
on the trampoline and then Stella gets
in there with them and they are bouncing
around and this fish is flopping and
it's almost hitting them like you know
they're doing that I'm like all right
it's been long enough let's put it back
in the water water swam away that fish
had to be terrified like terrified well
their cousin came a Florida kid who
enough said there who fishes day
and is doing fishing tournaments so this
kid I mean I couldn't believe it he's 10
or 11 I mean it was like it'd be like if
a guide a fishing guy like he showed up
and he was like you got all the [__]
like you want you want to see some [__]
yeah you want to see some [__] I'll show
you some [__] I mean right away he was
pulling stuff out that I don't even have
the refence I I was pulling out was
Sunfish and bluegill and c I mean he was
like oh this bluegill you know what we
do I can use this bluegill as bait he's
like like slices it up and I was like
what he was we'll get a catfish with
this one throws it in sets it like he's
like we can go over here I'll come check
it in a minute I'm like all right it's
like a little kid and we go back he's
like hey I got the catfish it was a
catfish holy [__] this [__] big and I
was like what is happen and then every
day I mean it was like you know seven
eight fish in like 20 minutes and this
was like all day he was you know his
Catch and Release and like the then like
I go up to the house and then I hear
they're like uh they put a fish in the
pool I'm like wait what I'm like you did
not and they're like just one just one
I'm like don't [__] put fish in the
pool and they're like sorry I go great
then the next morning I see Ellis and he
goes uh we put the copper head in the uh
in the trampoline I go what the [__] did
you just say he goes the copperhead I go
the snake you got a you got a copperhead
snake what a copperhead is he in his his
cousin no his cousin I go what do you
mean he goes well I caught one and uh I
just took care of it I go what are you
talking did you catch it by like I'm
thinking by the back of his head I go
did you grab a snake like that he's like
no no it it swallowed like the whole
line like the they called it fishing
yeah they caught it fishing I have never
in my life heard of anything like that
and then he goes I go what did you do
with it he goes I put it in the
cooler and then I put the cooler on the
trampoline dead Le then he said I've
secured the premises and I
go I go thank you very much I go please
don't [__] with the Copperheads anymore
for real and I go those are really
dangerous and he's like I knew it was
dangerous that's why I put it in the
cooler and I was like secure the
premises premises are totally secured
now you uh you and I like to send each
other Carnival accidents did you guys
did you ever go to carnivals and stuff
like that growing up did yeah would you
ever let your kids get on carnival rides
now Carnival not Disney World
never never never no not a chance not
not a chance when you realize like I
look back and I'm like they all had
really nice teeth and I'm like oh you're
all meth heads running these things dude
yeah I mean I got puked on it one I
remember that ew you got someone's puke
hit you did you throw up everywhere no
the funny thing was I'm walking and it's
one of those it's like the the ferris
wheel that goes up it also spins so it's
like double spinning and I just feel
like flick flick flick flick like it
feels like raindrop e God and I'm
like and then I'm like oh it's vomit and
it was like you know when you're like uh
like dressing in the in the the way that
like you don't I I was never wearing
wife beers like undershirts but I was
that day that day at the carnival I had
one on so I was able to take off my puke
covered shirt throw it in the trash and
then just look like a Florida kid yeah
and like in your wife beat her oh it was
so disgusting though I saw I think told
you this before but I went to a carnival
it was right here in uh Sherman Oaks
back in the day and my friend Christy
and her roommate Rachel were um living
around the corner from me and I knew
them from Maryland they were younger you
met christe she loved year of the bull
remember you're like how does this girl
love you like that they're like do you
want to go get on the carnival rides and
I was like I'm not getting on them but
I'll walk over there with you guys and
walk around the carnival I like Carnival
they're like do you want to get on the
zipper and I'm like no someone's going
to die and as we're walking to the
zipper there's a lady [__] face down
on the ground okay the the swings have
stopped and we hear a siren go by and I
go I don't see the lady at first and I I
jokingly go oh they're coming here but
they go past but then all of a sudden
they stop in uturn and they come back
and here comes a firet truck and
ambulance on the grounds pulling over
and there's the lady laying there and
she's flown off the swings she's not
moving listen I'm not kidding you as
close as that couch is over there to us
this lady's laying here the zipper is
right here and this guy over here is
going two tickets and she is dead on the
ground this [__] said two
tickets and they start walking up and
I'll never forget Christy had a ponytail
at the time and I snagged her ponytail
and I pulled I go what are you doing
she's like what I go look her friend's
already in the zipper this guy's like
two tickets they went and got on and
they took this lady on the stretcher and
got out of here and then guess guess who
won there the next day the swings SS
gone bro can you imagine the impact with
which she hit the ground no flying like
that like you might be hitting the
ground like 50 m hour man F so hard uh
well we have some videos we're going to
watch tiet two
tickets she's dead right here like you
had to step over
her like that ain't us us you seen this
one here let's watch this one this was
uh this one in India yeah yeah oh I'm
familiar with this yep everything is
going well not so much oh my
God bodies everywhere bro dude that's s
like that's just a straight drop broken
everything oh what do you think happened
to this guy then let's see oh yeah oh
I've seen this one too I know exactly
what's going to happen on the right side
of the
frame this guy's just going
to
godam [__] I mean bro did it push him
through that gate he went yeah he went
out that Gap yeah holy [__] dude he went
through that Gap nuts it's nuts I
wouldn't get on any of that [__] none of
that no Carnival local Carnival no way
bro it really is just passing through
town and it's people that are passing
through town hell yeah and if you come
like hey the guy was running the swings
last night the late does the L di on guy
run the swings he he didn't have he had
missing ear you know some scars do you
know the guy missing I don't know who he
is at all he set up next to you at every
city I don't even I don't I keep my my
mind my own business I think you call
him a pesky Pete something like that I
heard you guys say you didn't see the
lady died right in front of your zipper
last nightm no I was just yelling for
tickets I just got here no you
didn't all right what else do we have
for Tom let's see ever see this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh this is burp in your arm right now
look he's just like get up man why you
[__] around [__] you got to show me
that again this guy he runs out dude
good hit once hit
twice and there's a guy sitting in the
car yeah he's like what come on man he's
like come on man qu [__] around don't
[__] up with my
car that's exactly like this is perfect
he does
boom boom he's lucky he flipped like
that oh yeah shoe comes off right here
look at it look boom H what are you
doing man like come on man the way he
pulled him up he was like disappointed
don't be laying there also you imagine
your spine's probably broken he's
grabbing too he just yanking yanking you
you got to stand up oh yeah this is a
good one look at this right here to
watch where that horn goes oh up his air
h no he's he's very damaged look at him
he's like
oh it's right his whole Colon's
destroyed his whole [__] is destroyed
Jesus Christ I also saw one with You'
seen that one with the lady yeah she
runs out and it just not runs out you
know what I'm talking about the one
where the so the bull comes out and
there's four yes like and it goes at her
first goes and her neck snaps and she's
down her arms just go up yeah she's done
she's done dude I've also seen the one
with the bubbles the where the bull hits
the guy in the bubble ball have you seen
that uh oh and he goes into the low
Concourse of the stadium from the middle
of the [__] Arena dude that's what
you're [__] with yeah that's a
realistic example of how strong that
animal
is it launches him out of the put into
the lower Concourse have you seen that
look that one up real quick can you get
that one but that lady though is yeah
let's watch the lady di you have that
one we'll get it real quick here I have
it so I mean she goes yeah this is her
that's her right there that's going to
be it it's just going to go I like her
lady on the right
yeah all right let's go here should I
Doom she's
donee her neck snaps back no one's
trying to help now he's telling him get
out look she's just over there like all
right no one's helping
her
bro look how hard it hits it hits her
show that again
boom oh God that's it just over it's
over is there any update on her like
they used to they do this game called
have you seen C it's I think it's called
Cowboy poker or something like that and
these guys sit in a in a circle like
that with their backs to the bull and
they just sit and play poker and the
last one to get up from the table is the
winner and inevitably the Bull's coming
through oh sure and the last one that
gets up wins the money oh my god um I
did have a fun one here about neighbor
fights which I feel like um I saw on
your Instagram one time and
so oh they're mad about I'm not sure
what they're mad about but this how they
handle it we have permits okay was he Oh
what now you think that's bad he let the
dude on he hit him with a [__] no now
watch he does watch what he does with
the
wife what
what she gets harpooned now you got to
leave that in there you got to leave
that for a while W this is called fire
harpoons so that thing went through her
neck when it the explosion happened that
I'm not clear that's I'm I'm not sure of
and they're neighbors this is yes I just
know that it was a neighbor this feels
like it's eastern Europe though
right look at that look at that and cuz
and that lady just chilling right there
with her phone out is her phone out they
said this was a flame she was like go
get the thing and I'll I'll record it
look at that so how does it start again
it's just like it's just them arguing so
they're arguing she obviously is with
the the old the old guy cuz she yeah
she's like where's the lady in here that
gets the thing through her face is that
her right there sick of this guy's
[__] always out here her in this
video digging up holes and then he's
like why don't you [__] you know what
[__] I'll tell you what how
about that
for yeah
yeah but how did that happen how did
that
happen oh my God Jesus Christ yeah she's
she's like so startled you know how you
kill this woman right now right is by
just taking that out yeah yeah which
they're trying to do from they're trying
to yank that [__] like
on her chest let me I pull hard oh this
is one of my favorites have you ever
seen this Subway sandwich maker high on
heroin oh yeah yeah yeah eat fresh man
to look the Hat the r hat about to touch
it's touching me touching this look
she's kissing
it this guy is filming sandwich she just
sleeping on look at her sleeping on it
going to have to explain why he wants
another one you know he'll be like she
he'll be like your
face your face was all over it I didn't
know that was the top you know when you
put your face on it that's just one of
my face dude heroin dude heroin oh you
ever see this all right wait man give me
a give me over under let's say over two
inches how long you think this nail is
going to be comes out of this dude's
[__] face I thought you gonna ask me
about pints of blood I'm about to see
believe it or not no no
uh all right I think it's going to be
[__] when you see it tell me if you
think it's okay what you thought it
might
be Jesus how did he get those old school
pliers
dude look how long that nail is look at
that
[__] what was the craziest wound you
had as a kid growing up or
C1 I mean I remember the craziest thing
where I was like no way was taking a
pair of pants stepping through it and
not realizing that there was a really
sharp pencil like in the like the pant
leg somehow and so when I stepped like
this it went all the way up in my foot
like so I had to pull a pencil that was
like still have a scar from that I don't
I don't even I don't think I've looked
yeah still have a scar where hell it
go oh told my knee my knee from third
grade when a kid me this a scar it's
next to one of my I forget if it's this
eye or this eye this eye right here see
it that's from the nightstand when I was
like fell and hit it when I was like 78
roll over hit it right hits
this um I tell my mom because there's
blood and she like she's like oh okay I
you know she like dabs it like go to bed
in the morning I wake up and I notice
that my pillow's gone and I'm like
where's my pillow and they were like I
could see them and they're like uh and I
go into the laundry room and it's just
red it's soaked with blood so I bled
into it like all night like soaked look
like a
homicide that's the just from this cut
on the side of
the all right we got to get time out of
we have any questions anything else oh
just one more okay there we go you take
us back to what was going on with you
around this time what's going on with
number
32 before injuries baby Shack right
there that's what they call me how old
are you here baby Shack that's uh that
is Lakes Shore Middle School in mecan
Wisconsin that's the B team I was on the
B Team you were
yeah B teamk basketball team that was
probably it's either seventh or eighth
grade I want to say eighth grade I think
it's eighth grade um did you want to
play basketball was that something like
your I I love playing basketball yeah I
loved it and why B team was it an age
thing or were you just not that good yet
I just like there was the black
eyes like Benny Cleveland and Benny
Cleveland sounds like a 36y old black
man and uh and uh quow Taylor quow yeah
quow Benny they were on the 18 you're
definitely not getting on that team just
listen to the names n dude qu Taylor and
then we go from this school uh over to
Homestead which was like a at the time
it was like 2600 2800 and and uh I play
freshman football getting ready for
basketball we moved during the year but
at that at that school I remember that
those guys were in the high school gym
doing like windmill wind yeah there's
home yeah there's Homestead that's where
that's yeah there you go look you're
pretty Tom yeah you're pretty there 63
and
32 yeah there I remember there's a guy
named auma who was like that's pretty
Tom right there pretty
Tom yeah those were the days dude thank
you thank you for being our first guest
kicking this podcast off here letting
princess lay here with us pleas princess
is gorgeous um she's a fun little sweet
lady she's going to be coming on the
episodes and hanging out love it um
thank you dude plug anything you'd like
to plug uh yeah just um check me out on
tour I'm sure by now I've announced the
tour so go to toms.com
tour and uh come see see me live all
right there it is as always Ryan sickler
on all your social media come see me
live all tickets available Ryan sickler
if you're going to go to a show make
sure you get two tickets two
[Music]
tickets
oh